the jurogan experience yeah it's been an
interesting uh
year or so but man it's been it's been a
good year what was the the craziness
like like when all the people were
calling you a plague rat and
i mean it's it's you and how do you say
the guy's name the tennis player
novak djokovic yeah djokovic i mean
we talk about the healthiest human
beings on earth professionally
in the us open now yeah i know because
of this which is bananas
the guy's already had kovid recovered
from it i think he had it twice yeah and
he's one of the best athletes in the
world i mean the guy's body's in tip-top
conditions players are oh credible
fitness incredible yeah yeah and no you
can't come
you didn't follow the rules
like it's it defies science defies logic
it doesn't make any sense
none of it makes sense especially at
this stage of the the pandemic air
quotes
i mean what the [ __ ] man
what was it like for you it was it was
really difficult for sure and a lot of
different reasons i think
i knew
that this was coming down that at some
point
i was going to talk about my status
because i'd chosen to not get vaxxed for
reasons that you talked about
on your show and i talked about on we
should just say it because uh it's kind
of important you
you're allergic to a medication
or a part of the vaccine right what is
it called peg polyethylene glycol
and
uh
so i did my research um
i now i think typically speaking because
i'm healthy
and i take care of myself
getting vaccinated was not on the top of
my list but
you know i wanted to look into it
because everybody was doing it and
talking about it and and trying to be
safe and i wanted to make sure i was you
know doing my part if that's what was
necessary to keep myself safe and my
loved ones safe and my teammates safe
then i looked into it and at the time i
went on the cdc website and they
specifically said
you know if if you're
allergic to pg we do we do not recommend
you get vaccinated with the mrna
vaccinations so the only other one
available is johnson johnson and it just
got pulled
at the time for blood clots
so
i looked into other options which
included
an immunization process through
a holistic doctor and i researched and
talked to
probably a dozen different md's
and
found a protocol
that i felt like was was the best
available and what is that what what's
involved in that it involved um
basically uh
a couple month process of taking a
diluted
um
strand of the virus
so i was doing
basically what the vaccine is supposed
to do without how do they do that
i don't know the the
the exact way that they did that but
um
but it was by injection no
no it was it was um it was oral
and
how are they even getting a diluted
strand of the virus
i don't i don't know that exactly or
want to get into that exactly i don't
think
but
um but there was
uh hundreds and hundreds if not
thousands of people that i knew in this
circle that that we're using
that have been doing this to protect
ourselves because we were thinking hey
look uh
yeah for me i
didn't want to risk anaphylactic shock
uh or any type of clotting with you know
associated with the vaccine so
um
so that was my only option either do
nothing or do this process and i felt
like that this was the best way to
protect myself and my teammates and that
the nfl
would
understand you know and maybe grant me a
waiver because one of the most difficult
parts about the whole process was that
there was clearly two
classes of player at the facility there
was the vaxxed and the unvaxed and the
vax had full privileges
they tested once every two weeks
they had full
privileges on the road
they could
go out to dinner on the road they could
go to a concert in town they could go to
a comedy show that was it was in town
they could be at any place they wanted
to right and live life normally
non-vaxxed fully masked
zero privileges on the road could not go
into establishments more than 15 people
you cannot be around
more than uh three
uh
the three individuals from the team
outside the facility
all these different
what i think now we all realized were
crazy
uh
policies
and
that's what actually got me in into into
trouble was
that i attended
a halloween party in a 10 000 square
foot warehouse with 18 other individuals
all fully vaccinated and myself not
vaxxed
and was eventually fined for that
end up getting covered from
a vaccinated teammate of mine who
contracted covid
and
spread it and that's where it gets a
little bit crazy and i told this story
i think on the mcphee show but i said
when i came to
camp they knew i was not vaccinated
right so you had to
you had to submit a vaccination card
that went to the system with the nfl
and obviously i didn't have one so i was
given we were given wristbands too so
everybody in the facility knew
who was vaxxed and who wasn't vaxxed
vaxxed was green
non-vex was yellow
so already it's weird
yeah you know like
wearing your colors
out there
and i think you know to to do an aside
here there was a lot of shaming involved
in it
there was a lot of public shaming
that was attempted
to coerce people to get vaccinated
because not only you're wearing a yellow
wristband you're the only ones wearing
masks
and you you have to work out by yourself
can't work out with your teammates so no
drills nothing well you could at
practice
but weight room stuff or our weight room
every day
we're working out on the side just the
seven of us not back is it because
practice is outside and the weight room
is inside is it easily yeah
but
so they knew my vaccination status from
the start
as did all my teammates it was a lot of
talk about i endangered my teammates and
you know i lied to my teammates and my
team from day one that i returned which
was july 25th probably
of 2021 they knew
where i was at everybody did
also on the side i had an appeal going
with the nfl because i said look here's
my
health issues here's the protocol i went
through
here's the research behind it gave him
500 pages of research
from a number of people that put
together
case review studies around homeopathy
and
immunizations
and safety in them and also the efficacy
of them and then i had a conversation
with the league and the league said
in this conversation this one i knew
that my appeal was definitely not going
to happen was they said
it's not possible for a vaccinated
player a person sorry to
contract
or transmit codeword if they've been
vaccinated
and i said you got to be kidding me
because i showed up
and five people
non-players five people fully vaxxed
are out with covid
so what are you talking about
and he said you're a conspiracy theorist
oh boy
and i said
no i just think i'm a realist i'm just
looking at the facts here like what
point in the pandemic was this this was
like beginning of august
2021
so by then they had already known that
breakthrough infections were real
by then it had already i mean the the
vaccines started being rolled out
um
was it when what was the first year
it was january of 2020 where they
started getting them to older people
right
no
right i'm sorry january 2021 rather
sorry yeah january 2021 they started
giving out to older people wasn't that
they started rolling out in march and
april because that's when i was going
through the process of researching and
looking into what i could do right to
protect myself having the you know the
allergy that and by august people were
still they were already getting it
even though they had been vaccinated
so this was not you know
it wasn't talked about i don't think a
whole lot right but it was four months
and it was definitely happening so it
was definitely happening yeah yeah i had
only known one person at that time
somewhere around april that had
been vaccinated and also garcovet and i
just thought it was an aberration
i didn't based on what i saw in the
first few weeks at the facility and
that's why
i thought there was an opportunity
um but it was difficult because
we were separated there's a whole other
situation that was going on
that
uh
you know
also was going on in
in the rest of society is that
my
non-vax teammates who were on the bubble
right so 53 guys make the active roster
16 on the practice squad
so the 69 guys in the squad there's 90
in camp
right so of the i say seven i think
there's about 10 guys not vaxxed
only a few of us were guaranteed roster
spots like we were going to be on the
team and there's a lot of bubble guys
the general managers
and there was
there was talk around the league out
general managers
were not going to keep bubble non-vax
players right so they're already up
against it not only
did
the non-vax players have a harder chance
of making the squad but they also
had an almost zero percent opportunity
to get a workout afterwards so if you
get cut right and the season starts
every tuesday during the football season
most teams will bring in anywhere from
five to 15 guys for workouts just to see
who's out there
is there any players that can add to the
roster
so if you weren't vacs do you had a very
low percentage not just of keeping a job
but even getting a job
opportunity like a you know a workout
which is wild and
so after this conversation with the
league i knew that
my appeal was going away and they were
doing this i called it a witch hunt you
know where they were asking every single
player
are you vaccinated
you know they're asking a bunch of big
quarterbacks
and some guys were saying you know it's
you know
you know it's personal or whatever you
know i didn't want to talk about their
status and almost guaranteed you weren't
vaccinated right so then they were
getting ripped and certain guys said yes
i'm vaccinated and you know then they
try to get them to say [ __ ] about their
teammates
you know who weren't vaccinated like dog
their teammates out so i'd been ready
the entire time for this question
and had thought about how i wanted to
answer it
and i had come to conclusion i'm going
to say
i've been immunized
and if there's a follow-up
then talk about my process but thought
there's a possibility that i say i'm
immunized
maybe they understand what that means
maybe they don't maybe they follow up
they didn't follow up
so then i go the season
them thinking
some of them
that i was
vaccinated right because they fought the
only follow-up they asked was
basically asking me to rip on my
teammates like what do you say to your
teammates who are vaccinated like what
kind of example do you feel like you're
setting you know
to your teammates or a vaccine i said
it's everybody's own decision with their
body and
we're super healthy individuals we take
care of ourselves we understand what
goes in our bodies and
i don't have any judgment on any
decision that a guy makes with their own
body right but i knew at some point
if i contracted the covid or if word got
out
because it's the nfl and there's leaks
everywhere
it was possible i'd have to answer the
questions and then sure enough
i can track of it in uh
at the beginning of november end of
october
um
and that's when the [ __ ] storm hit
because
now i'm a liar i'm in you know
endangering
uh you know the community my teammates
all these people
and the you know
you know that the attempted takedown of
me and you know my word and my integrity
uh began but
um
so that was that was difficult but i
will say and and i'm thankful to be on
this show like
i really appreciate you and
you helping me out during that time i
reached out to you
uh i think begin the season i feel like
and just said hey
because you talked about in your podcast
a little bit you'd had some
uh you know controversial maybe less
controversial now um people on there
talk a bit less controversial now
talking about their
uh you know they're actually people
experts in the field talking about you
know their own
uh ideas about coveton and uh
and
you know you helped me with a uh
you know a game plan to be ready in case
i did get covered and
and
i followed it to a t and when i got
covered you know within 36 hours i was
you know symptom free and feeling
amazing but the protocols was
you're off for 10 days so i missed a
game
we lost a football game i came back had
to answer a ton of questions about it
obviously had my you know
basically
i lost
you know the majority of allies i
thought i had in the media the good
thing is it drew a real line in the sand
and everybody who wanted to jump on me
and and trash me did and showed their
true colors and very few people
uh
you know
kind of in the media at least
stuck by me
you